hello bonjour bandji à bienvenue dans
cette nouvelle édition d'en quête
d'europe dans cette émission je vous
emmène en autriche
là-bas pour juguler le chômage des
jeunes ont misé sur l'apprentissage
direction ensuite le portugal un pays en
crise qui a pris déjà depuis quelques
années le virage des énergies
renouvelables enfin terminus en roumanie
où de plus en plus d'agriculteurs
étrangers achètent et cultive des terres
arables mais d'abord on part en irlande
depuis déjà plusieurs mois le
gouvernement claironne la crise est
derrière nous alors info ou intox
c'est faustine saint-geniès qui nous en
parle faust il est ce qu'on peut
vraiment dire que l'irlande est sorti
d'affaires quand on est allé en irlande
le pays venait de sortir du plan net de
la troïka fmi bce commission européenne
un plan d'un énorme de 85 milliards
d'euros demandés en novembre 2010 alors
à l'époque dublin et traverser une crise
financière sans précédent la bulle
immobilière volet d'exploser l'économie
était exemple le pays a suivi à la
lettre le plan d'austérité
aujourd'hui c'est le premier pays
d'europe à sortir d'un plan dette de la
troïka et fait exceptionnel avec de
l'avancé sur le calendrier
alors est ce qu'on peut dire que le
tigre celtique se remettent à rougir pas
vraiment mais ils se remettent à miauler
bon bah écoutez on vous suit à dublin
bienvenue à silicon ducks dans le
quartier du canal à dublin
les immeubles flambant neuf ou remplacer
les vieux entrepôts aucun logo apparent
mais derrière ces murs amazon facebook
youtube
paypal tous les géants du web ont leur
pied-à-terre ici à commencer par google
qui ne cesse de s'agrandir
suite à côté aussi appartient à google
suit qui est derrière nous et puis ici
qu'à côté moi aussi donc il continue à
embaucher tous les jours ça va encore
mais derrière ça n'arrête pas une
aubaine pour constances mas s'est
expatrié à dublin qui a perdu son
travail en février dernier et mis mon cv
à jour sur internet et j'ai été démarché
tout de suite donc trois semaines avoir
après avoir appris que j'étais licencié
le secret de l'irlande pour attirer les
entreprises
son impôt sur les sociétés à 12 et demi
pour cent l'un des plus bas d'europe
et malgré la crise la question de
toucher à cette fiscalité très
avantageuse à sa connaissance en temps
de crise la dernière chose à faire dans
une politique industrielle
c'est de créer de l'incertitude c'était
important pour nous de garder un impôt
sur les sociétés à 12 et demi pour cent
il est resté à ce niveau et ne changera
pas
quatre ans après la crise l'irlande est
le premier pays à être sorti du plan de
sauvetage de l'union européenne et du
fmi
mais au prix d'une cure d'austérité
drastique le discours officiel se veut
optimiste
pourtant les stigmates de la crise sont
encore bien visibles
après l'explosion de la bulle
immobilière comme ce centre commercial
fantôme sur les docks et dans la
banlieue de dublin
on ne compte plus les rues abandonnées
comme ici à priori road jack audio a
subi de plein fouet la récession
il y a 6 ans elle était chef
d'entreprise et sa maison valait 1
million et demi d'euros
elle a perdu 90% de sa valeur
l'édile comment battre bien ces temps-ci
assieds-toi mère après un divorce et la
faillite de son entreprise
elle a connu une descente aux enfers
j'ai pensé au suicide pendant les six
mois où j'étais au plus mal
je ne peux pas dire que je ne vais pas
envisager j'ai su ce que c'était que
d'être au bord du gouffre j'ai su ce que
c'était que de ne plus avoir aucun
espoir très heureusement j'ai deux
enfants ce qui m'a empêché de passer à
l'acte
la banque a fini par saisir sa maison
jill se retrouve avec une dette de plus
d'un million d'euros
pour l'aider dans ses démarches débit
drôle
il a fondé un organisme qui aide les
irlandais surendettés aujourd'hui il y a
deux irlande une qui s'en sort et une
qui n'arrivent pas à joindre les deux
bouts
les statistiques le prouvent le seul
chiffre qui n'a cessé d'augmenter depuis
le début de la crise c'est bien
l'endettement des ménages
désormais jean n'a qu'un rêve repartir à
zéro
j'espère que lundi prochain j'aurai
suffisamment de retard de paiement pour
être déclaré en faillite personnelle
la banqueroute nous retrouvons constance
qui vite à dublin depuis trois ans et
demi traductrice de formation à 26 ans
elle gagne environ 2000 euros net par
mois
avec frédéric une amie expatriés elle
aussi elle voit dans l'irlande un
eldorado réservé aux étrangers
ici les entreprises américaines basent
leur leur siège européen et dans chacun
entreprises américaines on va avoir une
équipe française une équipe espagnole
une équipe portugaise allemande
et donc si on parle une langue
européenne
on a plus de chance de trouver de
trouver un bon travail ici j'ai des amis
qui sont irlandais qui enchaîne les
stages ou les tentatives de formation
pourrait essayer de s'en sortir parce
que à dublin le travail il n'est pas
pour aider pour nous le chômage touche
en effet 13 % de la population est plus
du double chez les jeunes même les plus
diplômés quittent le pays
professeur de finance à trinity college
charge larkin voit ses étudiants
immigrés comme sean connery
bonjour chaîne bonjour comment allez
vous pas mal on m'a donc cours en master
i lie à presque 100 % des étudiants
irlandais qui partent titulaires d'un
master en finance chez une comme il y
enchaîne les petits boulots les
entreprises où je travaillais ont fait
faillite
mon patron a perdu son bien hommage les
civils c'est très dur de se débrouiller
ici nos copines à deux masters et gère
un restaurant survivre en irlande est
une vraie lutte que vous voyez c'est un
effet d'optique
l'état veut une belle histoire l'europe
veut une belle histoire et ils vont y
travailler que ce soit la réelle
depuis 2008 plus de trois cent mille
personnes ont quitté le territoire pour
l'essentiel des moins de 35 ans faustine
finalement c'est un rebond en demi
teinte cette reprise hernandez
oui clairement un rebond en demi teinte
on voit que les entreprises étrangères
affluent on a google amazon paypal
facebook
elles ont même créé 13 mille emplois
l'année dernière en irlande mais
l'afflux est surtout liée à ce taux
d'impôt sur les sociétés record
l'irlande est à douze ennemis % pour
info la france est à 33%
c'est l'un des plus bas d'europe et iran
dit tiens d'ailleurs du blanc c'est à
batailler ferme avec la troïka pour le
garder et honnêtement je pense que ça a
permis d'atténuer un peu de limiter la
casse au niveau de l'emploi notamment
puisque le taux de chômage est encore
considérable
et puis on a encore les stigmates de la
bulle immobilière avec un parc de
logement vide énorme
il ya aussi le problème de l'émigration
ma jeunesse irlandaise en gros il n'y a
aucune possibilité de trouver pour eux
un emploi sur le territoire alors c'est
très difficile on l'a vu dans le
reportage est d'ailleurs l'irlande
redevient une terre d'émigration net
depuis le début de la crise vous avez
300 milles irlandais qui ont quitté le
pays
sur quatre millions et demi d'habitants
ce qui est énorme elle a fait une espèce
de bond considérable en six ans elle est
passée de la terre d'accueil de l'europe
avec un taux d'immigration le plus élevé
d'europe à à une terre de départ ce qui
était un peu le refuge les irlandais au
moment de crise il quitte le pays donc
c'est un peu un retour en arrière pour
l'irlande en quelque sorte mais on peut
espérer que la reprise se poursuive et
qu'à terme il y ait de vrais emplois
créés pour les irlandais dans le pays
merci faustien merci n'aura si les
jeunes irlandais s'exilent pour trouver
du travail
en autriche les autorités ont misé sur
l'apprentissage pour garder leurs jeunes
générations un exemple pour bon nombre
de pays européens dont la france
et c'est paul bouffard qui nous en parle
s'il y a un fléau en europe c'est bien
le chômage des jeunes
et oui 5.5 millions de jeunes de moins
de 25 ans sont au chômage aujourd'hui au
sein de l'union européenne et il y à une
exception c'est l'exception autrichienne
alors on a voulu se rendre compte
pourquoi en autriche il n'y a que 9 5 %
des jeunes au chômage contre près de 24%
en france c'est peut-être grâce à
l'apprentissage la formation d'apprentis
est choisi par 40% des jeunes de 15 ans
là bas ce qui leur assure un travail à
la sortie du coup on est parti à vienne
pour se rendre compte ces petits
bonhommes bleus sont le symbole d'une
réussite
un modèle à l'autrichienne où l'apprenti
est roi jean marc ayrault est venu
chercher des solutions au problème du
chômage des jeunes en france
ici le taux de chômage des moins de 25
ans est un des plus bas de l'union
européenne
8,7 pour cent seulement il est encore
tôt qu'en radovan enfile son bleu de
travail dans la banlieue de vienne la
capitale autrichienne
c'est le début des cours au centre
d'apprentissage ou ghanam vers qu
entendez la jeunesse au travail
le jeune homme s'équipent et sous l'oeil
de son formateur il s'exerce à la
soudure de ce qu'on lui doit le
consolider et le mesurer ok ok tu sais
faire accès de machines c'est bon pour
toi ok comme radovan 40% des jeunes
autrichiens vont vers l'apprentissage
depuis 2008 chaque jeune qui terminent
l'école obligatoire à l'âge de 15 ans
est en droit de recevoir une formation
quand ils ne la trouve pas seuls l'état
autrichien l'orientent le suit et le
format un métier radovan lui veut
devenir sidérurgiste je prends vraiment
plus de plaisir à travailler ici plutôt
que d'être simplement ainsi à l'école je
suis très confiant sur le fait trouver
un emploi le secteur de la métallurgie
est très demandée surtout quand on a
reçu une bonne formation
on est presque sûr de trouver un travail
en sortant d'ici ici on s'organise en
atelier autonome moins de quinze
apprentis par classe la journée débute à
7h15 elle s'achève à 16h15 c'est presque
la même chose quand l'entreprise ici
sauf que là nos profs prennent vraiment
temps pour bien nous expliquer ce qu'on
doit faire c'est pour ça que ça me plaît
l'autriche le royaume de l'apprentissage
comme son voisin allemand
il fait figure de modèle et c'est depuis
ce bureau du pôle emploi autrichien que
le système est piloté là on peut voir
juste au milieu de l'écran le chiffre du
chômage dans le pays
et juste au dessus là vous voyez on peut
lire le chiffre de près de 3000 nouveaux
chômeurs aujourd'hui avec ses écrans
johannes coop est à la tête de la ms le
pôle emploi autrichien quand certains
voient des effets pervers du à
l'orientation trop précoce dès 15 ans
lui y voit la raison de la réussite
il ya d'abord ce test c'est important de
savoir ce qui intéresse les jeunes
la première question que veux tu faire
est déjà mauvaise la réponse est souvent
rien
la question doit être est ce que ça
t'intéresse c'est aussi ce que veulent
les entreprises les entreprises veulent
des gens enthousiastes qui communique on
se rappelle une somme est avec un goût
de community l assiette victory
trois années d'apprentissage avec à la
clé un certificat est une réussite
garantie près de 90% des jeunes trouvent
un emploi
les entreprises sont friandes de ces
jeunes qualifiés et pendant sa formation
le jeune homme est même payé 300 euros
par mois la première année 700 euros
pendant la dernière
ici j'apprends je ne suis pas là pour
l'argent j'acquiers des compétences pour
plus tard c'est surtout pour ça que je
suis ici il y à un total une soixantaine
de centres d'apprentissage dans tout le
pays l'autriche consacre l'un des plus
gros budget de l'union européenne et
pour l'état c'est un gros investissement
130 millions d'euros pour faire
fonctionner le programme yoga nam werk
le ministre du travail est lui même un
ancien apprenti employeurs et employés
ont travaillé ensemble pour créer ce
système de formation et il continue à le
développer constamment
ça a toujours été notre priorité à
l'autriche de donner du travail aux gens
même en cette période de crise plutôt
que de payer des allocations chômage
nous préférons investir de l'argent pour
qualifier les gens en classe radovan et
ses camarades suivre aussi des cours
théoriques compris dans la formation
aujourd'hui son avenir est tout tracé je
trouve l'apprentissage très important
car ensuite les portes sont toujours
ouvertes si on veut faire un autre
métier
et si on n'y arrive pas on peut toujours
se réorienter dans le secteur de sa
formation
les entreprises doivent chercher des
employés qualifiés
c'est très important qu'on ne sait pas
exactement on va travailler plus tard
lutter à tout prix contre ce chômage des
jeunes en autriche à un objectif zéro
chômeur en 2016 pour les jeunes
déscolarisés l'information deviendra
obligatoire et les sanctions seront
lourdes jusqu'à des amendes pour les
parents
voilà en quoi l'autriche est un exemple
pour ses voisins européens c'est en tout
cas une volonté de l'état de mettre en
avant l'apprentissage en alternance
depuis 2008 l'autriche applique la
garantie jeunesse c'est une sorte de
label qui promet aux jeunes une
formation on appelle ça la ligue 1 anne
berck 6 à 18 ans vous n'êtes pas en
apprentissage ou en stage et bah c'est
l'état qui vous prend en charge et c'est
le pôle emploi autrichien qui va payer
alors j'ai visité différents centres à
vienne ce que l'on peut dire c'est que
ces jeunes sont très motivés et il y a
beaucoup de respect vis-à-vis de leurs
formateurs et contrairement à la france
on valorise beaucoup les formations
techniques et est ce que ce schéma est
transposable en france mais en tout cas
ça inspire le gouvernement français nous
sommes à la traîne en terme de chômage
des jeunes et quelques jours avant que
je vais j'arrive à vienne jean marc
ayrault l'ancien premier ministre était
en visite dans le pays
et aux dernières nouvelles la france va
bénéficier de 620 millions d'euros de
fonds européens
peut-être pour développer
l'apprentissage en france car en avril
dernier le taux de chômage des moins de
25 ans est reparti à la hausse dans
l'hexagone cette même garantie jeunesse
dont vous parliez pour l'autriche merci
paul créer des emplois pérennes et non
délocalisables et réduire sa facture
énergétique une nécessité pour le
portugal un pays qui ploie sous les
plans de rigueur successifs alors depuis
quelques années déjà les portugais ont
négocié un virage écologique sandra
cerqueira nous y emmène
sandra pour quelle raison le portugal
s'est lancé dans l'économie verte alors
tout simplement parce que le portugal
n'a pas d'énergie fossiles pétrole gaz
ou charbon donc ils ont été un peu
contraint de développer les énergies
renouvelables parce que ça leur coûtait
trop cher donc jusqu'en 2005 85 % de
l'énergie consommée était source
d'importation ce qu'ils représentaient
50% de leur déficit commercial
donc là depuis 2000 il ya eu une vraie
une vraie augmentation des énergies
renouvelables 70% même en 2013 de
l'énergie consommée était d'origine de
renouvelables et c'est vrai que c'est un
record en europe
il n'y a pas eu d'opposition au portugal
comme en france par exemple à
l'implantation de parcs éoliens parce
que ces sources d'emplois pérennes et
non délocalisables et ça aide aussi les
régions rurales à se développer
donc là on vous suit dans l'haleine
taiso difficile de les rater elles sont
partout au portugal les éoliennes font
partie du paysage
nous sommes à une quarantaine de
kilomètres de lisbonne
la proximité de l'océan aux fraudes et
vent favorable toute l'année georges ce
qu'elle est exploitant indépendant
il a vu dans l'éolien une énergie
d'avenir
quand la production d'énergie éolienne a
sextuplé en cinq ans et représente
aujourd'hui près de 40% de la
consommation nationale d'électricité
c'est le résultat d'un pari politique
pour améliorer notre indépendance
énergétique au portugal l'arrivée des
parcs éoliens n'a pas suscité
d'opposition
le développement massif de l'énergie
éolienne a été bien accueillie car pour
installer les parcs éoliens il a fallu
construire des routes améliorer
certaines infrastructures et cela a aidé
au désenclavement des villages isolés
les communes ont tiré profit de
l'utilisation de leurs terres et cela a
été vu comme une réelle opportunité
une bouffée d'air
une opportunité d'emploi également dans
un pays où le taux de chômage dépasse
les 15%
ce marché a permis à beaucoup de
portugais de retrouver le chemin du
travail
ce parc éolien il continue à bien
produire oui et les résultats sont
plutôt bons les techniciens avec
lesquels george collaborent se sont
formés récemment près de 40000 emplois
ont été créés avec les énergies
renouvelables les personnes avec qui je
travaille et qui assure la maintenance
ont suivi des formations de techniciens
en temps de crise c'est ce dont le pays
a besoin
nous avons ainsi pu garder une main
d'oeuvre formée qui sent le secteur du
renouvelable aurait quitté le pays
l'essor du renouvelable à aider à
dynamiser les régions les plus pauvres
grâce à l'implantation d'un tissu
industriel
c'est le cas dans la neige ou à evora
capitale de la région
bon nombre d'entreprises sont en
difficulté celle-ci spécialisé à
l'origine dans l'aéronautique se porte
bien
depuis qu'elle a misé sur le
photovoltaïque combien de plaques ont
produit aujourd'hui à peu près 500 à 600
par heure de nouveaux contrats à la clé
plus d'activités et des embauches
supplémentaires
ce gérant n'imaginais pas que les
énergies vertes pouvait être à ce point
rentable nous sommes mises à exporter
hors des frontières d'europe
il y a deux ans on a exporté vers les
émirats arabes unis puis vers les pays
du golfe
notre entreprise a vraiment pris une
nouvelle dimension
comment expliquer ce miracle le
portugais par manque d'énergie fossiles
ou nucléaires
le pays a toujours été contraints
d'importer alors produire de
l'électricité renouvelable a permis de
faire des économies
jusqu'en 2005 nous importions 85 pour
son énergie consommée cela représentait
la moitié du déficit commercial
portugais c'était intenable pour notre
économie depuis le virage énergétique
notre dépendance extérieure est moins
importante et continue de baisser en
enfant presque la totalité de
l'électricité consommée en 2013 est
d'origine renouvelable
un cas rare en europe résultat d'une
politique volontariste qui a débuté il
ya près de dix ans l'état a soutenu les
installations proposant des contrats qui
fixent un tarif de rachat de
l'électricité stable sur 15 ans et ce
afin d'attirer les investisseurs sur ce
nouveau marché
mais avec la crise l'attribution de
nouvelles licences a été gelé cet
ingénieur craint pour le développement
de la filière éolienne au moment où le
pays tente de développer le prototype
d'une nouvelle turbine d'éolien offshore
moins cher et plus efficace
le portugal produit parfois plus qu'il
ne consomme alors le véritable enjeu
selon lui c'est de pouvoir exporter
davantage la péninsule ibérique est
encore considérée comme une île au sein
de l'europe le portugal et l'espagne
sont connectés l'espagne et la france
aussi
mais ce n'est pas suffisant il faudrait
pouvoir exporter jusque dans le centre
de l'europe en développant les
interconnexions entre le portugal et les
autres pays membres pour connaissent
enfin un véritable réseau électrique
européen qui ont marre
et c'est une demande récente du
gouvernement portugais
persuadé que sans l'achat de la
production d'électricité verte du pays
il sera impossible d'atteindre les 27 %
d'énergies renouvelables au sein de
l'union européenne
l'objectif fixé par bruxelles pour 2030
sandra on voit bien dans votre reportage
que le portugal a entamé cette
transition énergétique pourtant ils sont
un petit peu isolé en europe non oui
c'est la péninsule ibérique dont ils
sont isolés avec l'espagne du reste de
l'europe
et aujourd'hui quand ils produisent plus
d'énergie qu'ils n'en consomment par
exemple l'enjeu pour eux c'est
d'exporter mais c'est pas facile d
exporte un peu en espagne mais c'est
impossible
au delà donc aujourd'hui ce qu'ils
souhaiteraient c'est voir se développer
un réseau électrique européen et c'est
vrai qu'en temps de crise c'est
difficile et on a aussi un autre
problème qui est que aujourd'hui on ne
sait toujours pas stocker l'électricité
oui au niveau de la commission
européenne on a 10 en 2010 que c'était
une priorité sauf qu'on est toujours au
stade de la recherche ya rien de concret
il n'y a aucune mesure réglementaire qui
incite est au développement de batteries
pour stocker l'énergie et c'est vrai que
dans ce contexte beaucoup se demandent
comment l'europe va atteindre son
objectif pour 2030 de passer à 27 %
d'énergies renouvelables vient vraiment
ou de réseaux entre les pays européens
donc ce sont quand même des obstacles
importants pour mettre en place cette
indépendance énergétique de l'europe
merci sandra quand les agriculteurs
européens ont du mal à acheter des
terres à cultiver il y a encore un pays
en europe qui offre des opportunités
c'est la roumanie alors pillage ou
nouvel eldorado des terres arables c'est
une enquête de marides remo
marie est ce que la roumanie est le
nouvel eldorado de l'agriculture
européenne
il faut savoir que l'agriculture romaine
n'est pas encore entré dans l'ère de la
modernité tout est encore possible tout
est à écrire doux l'eldorado romain pour
bon nombre d'investisseurs la roumanie a
d'ailleurs vocation à devenir le grenier
de l'europe et en roumanie
il y à de très très nombreuses petites
exploitations c'est d'ailleurs en
roumanie que le nombre d'exploitations
est le plus important au sein de l'union
européenne avec près de 4 millions et
c'est l'héritage en fait de l'ère post
communiste
en fait les fermiers craignent
aujourd'hui le collectivisme le
regroupement il est donc très difficile
de remembrer de forme et de grandes
exploitations capable d'être
concurrentiels sur le marché européen
donc on vous suit en roumanie où vous
vous êtes rendu avec mehdi chebana dans
la famille de denis thomas on est
viticulteur de père en fils depuis plus
de dix générations en plein coeur de la
bourgogne à nuits saint georges
alors je vous emmène dans l'ignoble donc
sur les coteaux et quatre cinquièmes de
nos vignes quand en 1995 le domaine
familial est vendu ce passionné sa femme
font leurs valises direction ça athènes
un petit village à 150 km de bucarest
je suis venu en roumanie
attiré par le pinot noir bon être temps
bourguignon c'est mon cépages de
prédilection et je cherchais pour
l'entreprise familiale que je dirigeais
à développer les pinots noirs de qualité
l'orientation l'amplitude thermique des
terrains calcaires et haïr et toutes les
conditions ici sont réunis pour un
terroir d'exception
mais si denis thomas s'est exilé c'est
surtout qu'en roumanie les terres
agricoles représentent encore de belles
opportunités l'hectare ici est 20 fois
moins cher que dans sa région natale
2000 euros lecteurs pour la terre non
plantés et 5000 pour des vignes plantées
en bon état 5 à 10 milles pour des
vignes plantées en vo net en bourgogne
c'est on commence à 60 milles pour finir
à 1 million d'hectares
le français est désormais à la tête d'un
domaine viticole de 70 hectares le fruit
de quinze ans d'investissement si denis
doit faire face à beaucoup de
tracasseries administratives
l'accueil des roumains a conforté dans
sa nouvelle vie dix salariés travaillent
à plein temps sur le domaine
bonjour bonjour tout mon respect qu'est
ce que vous faites
on laboure la saison a commencé ici le
regard porté sur les propriétaires
terriens étrangers et bienveillant et
surtout pragmatique c'est une bonne
chose qu'il vienne ici et qu'ils fassent
des affaires plutôt que ça reste en
l'état
c'est une bonne chose j'ai un avis
plutôt positif
s'il n'était pas venu peut-être qu'on ne
travaillerait plus
ap être propriétaire c'est un rêve
moi j'ai une propriété j'ai un hectare
de vigne c'est suffisant
pour nicolas et exploiter la terre pour
son propre compte et une lointaine
chimère
comme pour beaucoup de paysans room 70%
des terres reste consacré à une
agriculture de subsistance une
agriculture familiale à la mairie de
sare athènes la ruée des fermes les
occidentaux est perçu comme une
opportunité l'occasion de moderniser une
agriculture souvent archaïques dans la
région 30 % des exploitations agricoles
sont détenus par des européens
à 28 ans la dre on apprend beaucoup
auprès des étrangers
une association avec les étrangers a
toujours apporté de bonnes choses en
fait il ne travaille pas vraiment ils
ont apporté les machines les outils et
ce sont les habitants de la commune et
de la région qui travaillent pour
physicalité il n'y a aucun chiffre
officiel mais on estime que 10 % des
terres arables en roumanie seraient
détenus par des étrangers principalement
des européens depuis quelques années des
voix s'élèvent et dénonce un
accaparement du sol roumain avec
l'entrée du pays dans l'union européenne
et la libéralisation du marché foncier
il est bien plus facile d'acheter des
terres agricoles pour les investisseurs
étrangers
pour l'une des plus importantes
fédérations de syndicats agricoles
le problème est ailleurs je travaille
sur ce dossier
les collègues en ont besoin il faut que
je passe les voir la taille des
exploitations pour la plupart des mini
parcelle distribué à la révolution
roumaine ne sont pas à la hauteur du
marché européen
seule solution c'est l'association le
remembrement
c'est la seule solution qui permettrait
de sortir du marasme
car s'associer ça donne la possibilité
de mieux capitaliser les subventions la
possibilité de courir le crédit de la
banque car la surface est plus grande
mais s'associer c'est surtout la
possibilité de vendre la production un
prix bien plus avantageux la puissance
de négociation des paysans grandi depuis
bruxelles a accordé près de 10 milliards
d'euros à la roumanie exclusivement pour
l'agriculture et le développement rural
67 % de cette somme a déjà été utilisé
mais les petits paysans et les petites
exploitations roumaines ont toujours de
très grandes difficultés à accéder à ces
fonds marie est ce qu'on peut parler
d'accaparement des terres arables en
roumanie en étant sur place je me suis
rendu compte que le pillage des terres
agricoles roumaine était quand même
largement surestimée par les médias n'a
d'ailleurs aucun chiffre officiel sur
les terres arables détenus par des
étrangers en roumanie en tout cas bon
nombre de roumains que ce soit des
syndicats paysans les autorités
gouvernementales même des petits
fermiers vois cela comme une opportunité
parce que les européens apportent des
techniques du matériel et donc ça peut
faciliter la transition agricole
roumaine après il ya certaines
associations qui surf un petit peu sur
des relents nationalistes
donc attention aux discours et aux
postures des uns et des autres merci
marie voilà c'est la fin de cette
émission nous on se retrouve très vite
sur public sénat tous les jours sur
publicsenat.fr ciao
ce soir sur public sénat à 22 heures
bibliothèque médicis